le cuento que todo va quedando listo
para la transmisión de mando en perú las
autoridades han desplegado más de 4000
policías quienes brindarán seguridad al
presidente pedro castillo ya los
dignatarios que asisten a la
inauguración de este nuevo gobierno
podemos decir que pocas horas antes
pedro castillo ha tenido su primera
derrota política su partido perú libre
no logró conseguir la presidencia de
este nuevo congreso que haga requerido
en maría del carmen galván la derecha
controla el parlamento y va a ser una
oposición al nuevo gobierno pedro
castillo solamente tiene 37 congresistas
y va a necesitar tejer alianzas con
otras bancadas de otros grupos políticos
distintos al suyo para tratar de sacar
adelante de sus proyectos desde ya este
nuevo parlamento ha dicho que va a
rechazar la propuesta de pedro castillo
de convocar a una asamblea constituyente
para modificar la constitución se podría
decir que pedro castillo al igual que
sus antecesores pedro pablo kuczynski
y está condenado a trabajar con un
congreso de oposición que en cualquier
momento le puede aplicar según ellos han
analizado la vacancia presidencial o el
inpec